welcome back to new rock stars is one
division sitcom reality branding sword
infiltrators with flair
or are they following a super
self-defeating dress code
why did monica rambo out herself with
that sword necklace
and more importantly did she go to jared
i'm eric voss and this is rogue theory
with me today
is the uncut gems of the show tommy beck
told
hey eric guess what i'm not wearing
jeans again for the hundredth straight
day that's right
no zippers no buttons just cotton
and elastic that's all a growing body
needs
that's right and it is growing it's just
not growing the ways i want it to it's
going it will get there
um and like also with us the tiffany's
to my zales
marina mastros
[Music]
[Applause]
i love that oh man i fared way better
than tommy in that analogy
this is how i win
and we are thrilled to have back on the
show our friend comedian
and 24 karat solid gold dude tom
michelson
i was like what jewelry reference am i
going to get this will be a good one
they brought me back happy new year i
got my new rockstars beard like eric and
tommy so yeah let's go let's get it
going
marina where is yours oh back there
oh yeah oh no it's all party in the back
over there in the the background
all these uh jewelry puns are courtesy
of off-screen producer zack he
actually had the whole intro of the show
that kind of thing and i said we need to
tell people what the show is about at
the beginning stack yeah and he's like
all right
so let us talk about westview's
relationship with sword a little late in
this episode we're gonna keep talking
about wanda vision and finally figure
out what the hell
those hexagon images are about uh but
let's start with this question we've
been obsessing over these first three
episodes of one division
and you know by now we kind of know what
geraldine slash monica's necklace is a
reference to
and we've come up with some solid
explanations over what sword
is and what their mission could be but
we haven't really talked enough about
why would monica wear that necklace
actually kevin power
and i were discussing this on twitter
this week and he is on to something
it makes no sense for sword agents to
wear obvious flair that
identifies themselves if they're trying
to sneak in there it's like carol
danvers joking captain marvel with that
shield hat
does announcing your identity help with
the covert part of your job
yeah let's try to figure this out
together uh let's start with the theory
that
monica maybe didn't decide to wear this
necklace herself but that maybe
wanda's pocket reality might have a way
of
labeling or marking sword outsiders what
do you guys
think about this that's actually pretty
close to what i was thinking
um because actually my my sort of like
more fleshed out theory as i was
watching the show just like with my face
glued to the screen
just if you watch it pressed up against
the screen then you get more information
from it
yeah that's why i haven't been i missed
so much stuff that's why
yeah yeah you're sitting too far away
you have to scoot closer
um i think i think shield sent her in
um in episode two with the 60s outfit
or a 50s outfit whichever one is correct
john just
pick whichever one um and
when wanda updates everybody's outfits
should be the 60s she does it to
everybody with her powers right
and when she says
when she brings up wanda's brother i
think
her mind picks out
things that are threats to her reality
and
changes them so it's not her walking in
being like you know what i'm going to
put on
a shield necklace because that doesn't
you're right eric like that
or a sword necklace yeah or i mean sorry
a short a sword necklace
so it doesn't make it any sense for her
to walk in with a sword necklace that
doesn't make any sense but
i mean unless you want to sell merch
that that is
mixed we know the business angle for
this outside
i'm sure it's pre-ordered already yeah
yeah
i ordered 15. um so it is working okay
yeah um but when there's a threat
something shows up to wanda to mark that
person or to make them
show up to her so that she can eject
them right so the beekeeper's really
unusual
uh the helicopter turns red so it's not
monica coming in with something that is
gonna obviously set her apart but
once she makes that threatening that
remark that seems
threatening to wanda her mind changes
something on her to signal to her like
you have to get this person out of here
so monica
basically is like like looks down and
it's like oh [ __ ] and then she gets
booted so like she didn't walk in with
that but whatever necklace she was
wearing and i should go back and rewind
and make sure that that
i mean i wonder if anybody's done that
did she have it on in the beginning of
the episode
yeah i mean she did when she first
walked in uh the thing though
is did she have anything any kind of
sword flare in episode two
i'm not so sure i mean it might have
been tucked into her wardrobe
but like marina you bring up an
interesting angle there maybe
it was um wanda's subconscious mind you
know that just kind of it's like
protecting her
um yeah wanda you know she was surprised
when she thought she's like what does
that symbol mean
a lot of this might be wanda's
subconscious mind but does want a
subconscious mind
only recognize sword because all these
things have the sword logo
or anything threatening or is it just
that only sword
is capable of infiltrating this pocket
reality i wonder
more if it's not necessarily that it
recognizes sword
or if sword is the manifestation of
wanda recognizing something is off and
it keeps revealing itself as sort you
know
like almost like an animal knowing the
difference between a predator
and something that is not threatening
like yeah and we just keep seeing it
visually manifested
as uh as sword uh gear you know sword on
the helicopter
sword so i i my thing is i'm wondering
if
like anyone in that realm has a certain
amount of
uh amnesia anyone who goes in there no
matter what whether they were dressed
period appropriately or not they go in
with a certain
wardrobe and their minds are immediately
white by whoever is doing this magic
whatever
whatever whether this is artificial
intelligence or actual magic
and then i wonder if as things are going
on and as the reality starts to shatter
around them people's memories are coming
back more so i wonder if
geraldine slash monica really was just
starting to remember that stuff
in the moment there like if she if she
really had no idea what she was doing
there and thought that she was genuinely
supposed to be there
and that those those visual reminders
are clues to the viewer that these
people are starting to catch on to their
own
actual reality totally unintentional and
then she again
looks down and is like oh [ __ ] i had a
pretty great sword necklace when i was
in high school
me and all my friends had it and they
had a little sheath and when you took it
out there was a little bump of special k
on it
and then you put it back in and nobody
ever knew and that's why we all failed
math
because of the necklace but we passed
creative writing yes
you did great in theater i was thinking
like
and not to go rogue here i know we don't
really do that here but
whoa i can't help but think that like
maybe the necklace was on purpose
because what if it works in like
inception where it's like a token
that helps ground you and remind you of
who you are where you are
and by conception in this dream within a
dream you get lost
you know you can get lost very easily
and maybe maybe it's one of those things
where because
sword they weren't caught by wanda in
any way she found the helicopter saw the
logo so she was kind of planting
planting the figuring figuring it out
and you know
what the what was going on in the first
place and then
so by the time monica comes around she
doesn't necessarily know that maybe her
cover's blown
per se uh by the time when wanda's
really like
hey what that necklace and then because
i don't think monica's aware of the
beekeeper
i don't think she's aware that she found
a helicopter with the logo on it so for
her it's maybe it's something that
the sword agents use as a key or like
inception like a token to
keep them grounded and remember who they
are and then but then now she just got
yes sol when wanda was like what is that
get out of here yeah um i like that i
like that idea a lot
uh this idea of a token um and you know
what now that we're looking back on it i
wonder if
uh geraldine slash monica is monica
rambo going in there because she didn't
have any protective gear
the um the reality started to kind of
brainwash her
and that's why they had to send in the
second guy the beekeeper to try to go
fish her
out but then um you know wanda
stop that [ __ ] dead in its tracks and
then was able to sniff out the other
sword infiltrator do you guys think it's
like possible that
this pocket reality whoever's really
orchestrating that pulling the strings
has a way of manifesting
something's true nature so like all
these things are getting stamped and
marked with this sword logo because the
rules the reality know
that they really represent a sword
infiltration kind of like in uh
oz you know the wizard of oz uh once all
these things get translated
in uh dorothy's potential dream like the
wizard was
the the magician the the soothsayer
figure
who uh was able to tell her fortune uh
miss gulch gets translated
into the wicked witch of the west and in
the same way that in this reality
things that were on the outside have a
way of getting translated into a more
simplified um
sit commie version of it in this case
it's like a sword bee keeper it's monica
rambo wearing this sword necklace
is there anything to that totally
because also eric like you're talking
about
an emotional truth that also would
just makes itself known in everybody's
psychology
in general and she wouldn't really be an
exception to that just because she has
power so like you can
convince yourself that something isn't
true but you know it
is like deep down you'll dream about it
like if you really suppress something
you might dream about it or you might
like
to you know say to everybody else in the
world like no no
whatever i'm i'm a millionaire i'm
totally rich i have a bajillion dollars
and i i know that that's true but you
know eventually
you know deep down that that's a reality
so she can build this entire world to
convince herself
the vision is still alive that she gets
to have kids that all of this stuff is
happy happy happy
but deep down i think you're right she
knows subconsciously and it's like
leaking into her reality that she's
building to herself
for herself even though she kind of
doesn't want it to yeah i think what we
might find is like
the sword ones are the obvious ones to
us because we're still kind of figuring
out what this logo means but then
maybe we'll go back and look at these
episodes and find that like
other characters uh little things about
them were significant like
uh dottie being uh being kind of in
charge of this cul-de-sac she could have
like some kind of alternate role on the
outside
uh uh jones um with getting fired or
something like that uh herb cutting into
the wall
that maybe he is someone who's literally
trying to chisel uh his way
into the pocket reality and then did and
now he's still trying to cut down walls
like it'll be fun to see if there's some
kind of like analog to each of them
and that's why they're expressed the way
they are inside west view
one of them really just like 60s
clothing yeah
um do you guys think that there's
anything to this idea that maybe
all of this is soared and that it's kind
of like
every little sort of clue we're seeing
is just a version of westview trying to
signal to wanda hey
all of this is brought to you by sword
uh and that you know this
whole thing is a sword operation most
most definitely i think that's kind of
like we were talking about last week
with the truman show element of it that
these are all
pieces in this big giant game and one
reason i
think that that could be true is i
wonder if this is a defense mechanism
against wanda like if
maybe in the real world wanda is on the
verge of
doing something catastrophic and they've
kind of got her in a stasis right now
oh they have like they've used this kind
of like you know
last ditch effort to freeze her in time
and then trap her in
whatever this this world is as they're
trying to figure out how to calm her
down and get her to stop
or or persuade her subconsciously to
stop doing whatever she's doing like i
i don't i keep throwing my hands up like
she's literally like i'm doing her magic
but like
i guess you are scarlet witch civil war
god it's my dream to stand in front of a
green screen by the way and move my
hands like this
that guy's such an idiot but then when
it comes out i'm shooting lightning
bolts out
uh but uh yeah i i wonder like i'm just
picturing like when she when she threw
uh crossbones into the building in civil
war like if there's something
similar to like that destructive where
she's just got someone she's on the
verge of killing someone and so this is
all an effort to kind of defuse the bomb
but the bomb is scarlet witch yeah she's
bowling and they put safety lanes
bumpers yeah safety lanes now
based off of how episode three ended the
town of west view is there
in the real world it's not all an
illusion just in her head like we can
see from the outside looking in there
are structures there's a town walking
shine
but that all could have been like an uh
potemkin village right
um that they put wanda in and she's like
wandering around mindlessly but really
there's like they have some kind of
waves that are projecting in her head
this all that's around her or maybe it's
like a two-way thing because
i at the end of the day it's not barf
right it's not
uh sword warping to reality it's not
like that kind of false simulated
reality
because this is one division it uh wanda
the scarlet witch her
powers are to be able to rewrite reality
and warp reality
it's coming from inside her going
outward not outside or going in
and i mean i to that point like i i
understand it's a physical place but we
don't we haven't seen into that
place yet i mean i could literally not
not that i'm trying to defend this point
she could literally be in some sort of
like containment cell in the center of
the town that we haven't seen yet you
know like
she could still be it could still be i i
don't know anyway
yeah that she is
in control and in charge and and he's
warping things to how she sees fit i
mean you guys brought up last week too
that
maybe the the beekeeper suit is just her
her point of view on what a hazmat suit
coming through would look like and that
it looks like a beekeeper i think and
and then that goes all the way down to
like the outfits and how they look and
how everybody looks and at the same time
it clues us into like what again what
you've said before eric which is her
her powers uh stay stay
say reality even after you get ejected
from this world and so she's just in
some
in total control you know subconsciously
it looks like
of this entire situation and like how
how is that going to play out and that's
that's what brings everybody back like
holy crap what's happening in the show
i think um no matter who is really
behind this whether it's agnes
a mysterious third party that we've
talked about a bunch of different
options
grim reaper mephisto maybe aim or
something like that
um the the nature of this pocket reality
is such that they
are very good at labeling and marking
uh like what white blood cells within a
body
um foreign entities that have come in
and don't belong there so that tells us
something about what's really going on
right that it recognizes things that
should be in there and things that
shouldn't be in there
and have a way of translating them or
wanda to be able to identify and eject
things that are productive to her to
this or not yeah she doesn't really want
to wake up
like as much as she you know she wants
to stay in this reality and everything
that presents itself as danger to her
waking up to reality is a danger to her
but also everybody else so it's in
everybody's interest to be like no no
like stay in your
bumper lane in your bowling baby lane
just until like tommy was saying we can
get things under control and then like
gently ease her out because i don't
think anybody
is trying to like get her out
lickety-split like just shoot her out of
this reality because that's
super dangerous or it's like you know
they want a controller until they get
what they want
which yeah it could be that too well
this is still rogue theory and i still
award points to people in my mind
whenever i talk to them
uh i keep track in a meticulous
spreadsheet everyone's weaknesses their
strengths
their um benefits to society and ways
that they can spell doom
so uh the version of that in this pocket
reality is to manifest in golden sparkle
box
and uh the golden sparkle bug of this
uh segment will go to tom michaelson for
coming up with a
token of inception tokens i think that's
really cool i like that idea
when you said tom i i thought for sure
save time there's a drum roll after the
top
[Music]
gets a blue sparkle buck all right for
um
confessing his special k problem when he
was a young
yes yes former problem
now my only drug is candy it's my
strength and my weakness
sweet sweet candy candy is what i call
crack yeah yeah it's about to be like
uh-huh
marina gets a magenta sparkle
for jumping on the grenade first with
her take first out of the game
gets another little special point i'm
brave but not always right
you still get points for bravery well
we're gonna theorize more about
westview and what the damn hexagons mean
but
first this episode is sponsored by
bluechew
guys you now can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence
in bed with bluechew.com that's blue
like that color blue
blue chew is the first chew of all with
the same fda approved active ingredients
as viagra and cialis
you can take them anytime day or night
even if you're on a full stomach
to be ready whenever an opportunity
i like to eat a big bowl of alfredo
before i take my bluetooth i like to get
just the alfredo sauce no noodles mixed
in no chicken just
a sauce i simply can't perform unless i
carbo load and for me it's alfredo and
blue chew every time
yeah and that's hey uh you need that
sauce because
you need the sauce to make some voss
sauce that's what i say to myself every
day
somehow i'm in a relationship
yeah blue chew is made in the usa it's
prescribed online by licensed physicians
so you don't have to go to the doctor or
wait in line it's even cheaper than a
pharmacy
and they prepare and ship it right to
you in a discreet package
no awkwardness and you don't need to
leave the house though we know for tommy
he's fine either way he doesn't mind it
being shattered from the mountaintops
oh i i have a town crier deliver mine i
have him marching from main street all
the way to my house
and then i have him feed me one
ceremonially delivery for thomas
becktailed
bluetooth
hey eric i got a question are those uh
bucks uh those uh bucks here are they
really just foil wrappers open from blue
chew there's like a
there's like a strawberry flavor there's
blueberry and then now gold whatever
gold is right there
magnum flavor i'm not sure what oh shush
tom you're gonna lose your golden
um
folks blue chew is the fast and easy way
to enhance your performance
we've got a special deal for our
listeners visit bluechew.com and get
your first shipment free
when you use our special promo code
rogue just pay five dollars in shipping
that's it
again that's bluee chew.com promo code
rogue to try it free bluechu is a better
cheaper choice
and we thank them for sponsoring this
podcast and remember when you support
our sponsors you help make this podcast
possible so please be sure
to use our promo code rogue
bluetooth.com we also want to thank our
friends at audible for sponsoring this
episode
audible is a leading provider of spoken
word entertainment and audiobooks from
bestsellers to celebrity memoirs
languages business motivation and now
podcasts
for a second there we were just saying
nouns uh cactus
uh spaghetti eric i like a big bowl of
alfredo before i listen to my audio
books
you can slurp your alfredo sauce as loud
as you want
audible is still going to be crystal
clear and super entertaining
and life affirming because you're a
person who eats alfredo sauce by
the spoonful one thing i really
appreciate an audible
is all the great uh sci-fi and fantasy
content they have a huge collection of
star wars audio books
including the new ish thrawn and ahsoka
and leia solo books and now that like
all these things are going to be in live
action you got to go back and read these
books or just listen to them
via uh audible because they're so good
they're so well written
uh and you're gonna see you're gonna get
caught up on what dave filoni is
thinking
when he's making these into live-action
stuff and you'll see why they're so
great i also love when there's a
recognizable voice narrating a great
story like uh
tim curry does all of the lemony snicket
books uh
they also have mahershal ali maggie
gyllenhaal zachary quinto
a bunch of other great famous folks
narrating their thousands of titles it
feels like you're best friends with them
and they're just whispering
in your ear as you're going off to bed
that's what my best friends do
like tommy does uh tommy i've asked you
to get out away from my
uh second story window i don't know how
you're doing that
time for you to sleep eric time for you
to go
to sleep charlie brown was the saddest
little boy in the world
but he loved his dog snoopy oh i'm
falling asleep that's so
soothing i'm falling asleep over here oh
damn tommy snack
[Laughter]
oh and with audible plus you get full
access to the plus catalog which is
filled with thousands and thousands of
select originals
audiobooks podcasts including ad-free
versions of popular shows as well as
exclusive series
if you're a fan of true crime podcasts
they have a treasure trove of original
ones in audible
visit audible.com rogue theory or text
rogue theory to
500-500 to start your free 30-day trial
that's audible.com
rogue theory or text rogue theory to 500
500 to start your free 30-day trial
and finally new rockstars is excited to
announce that we
are partnering with the app stereo to
launch
three new weekly live shows the shows
will be live on the stereo app which you
can download for free at stereo dot com
new rockstars if you download using that
link you'll automatically follow us
and be notified about our new shows when
they're coming out with stereo you can
interact with our podcasts
in real time you can submit voicemails
that we will air
in the episodes as we're recording them
as you're listening and then we're going
to react to you
we're going to answer your questions
during the episodes uh so
these three new shows they're gonna be
exclusive to stereo
their podcasts are audio only so these
are the three uh there's gonna be an
expanded interactive version of our
inside marvel one division after show
with me and jessica clements that's
going to air every friday
at 8 a.m pacific standard time there's
going to be
what we're calling new rock stars news
it's really just going to be me and
philip casually reacting to the biggest
nerdy headlines of the week and
answering your questions about them
that's every wednesday at 1 p.m pacific
standard time and then we're launching
this new crazy thing called
comment comments with our editors john
costa and joshua heard
reacting to the comments on new
rockstar's youtube channel from the past
week and addressing your comments
and your concerns and various questions
you have had like um
why eric missed this thing or what is
the weird story behind this uh tiny text
that flashes on screen
uh that's gonna be every monday at 8am
pacific standard time
it seems like a dangerous game to play
it oh very very dangerous it might get
canceled after a week we'll see
um so to access these live shows and
submit us
your voicemail questions and theories
and interact with us in real time
you download the free stereo app at
dot com stereo.comrockstars.stereo.com
new rockstars okay back to wandavision
this show keeps bringing back hexagons
and the number six
so much so that i now kind of regret
ever bringing it up because people are
now tweeting me constantly with insane
reaches that like
monica is clearly octagonal earrings are
actually hexagons or
all the time codes at the specific time
add up to the number six uh six uh plus
five which is one less than six is 911
um or
you know random hexagons and other
movies and shows they must be connected
to the hexagons in this show
i get it the conspiracy blood is on my
hands i
rocked this you're cute you're q from q
anon
1 6 january 6 that's when it happened oh
my god um
right within wandavision it's possible
these hexagons that show up in the
sitcom editing of episodes one two and
three that's all i'm saying is connected
folks it's within the show episode
episode i think they could actually mean
something so let's
you know let's go rogue here let's let's
try to figure out what these hexagons
are all about uh and leading off with
the possibility that at least could be
connected to the hexagonal
aim logo you remember aim right that's
advanced idea mechanics that was
aldridge killian's company from iron man
3. in the comics aim is a much bigger
deal than it is in the mcu the henchmen
have these kind of beekeeper-esque
yellow jumpsuits
um aim is connected to modoc we've
talked about aim on the channel before
uh they might be coming back into mcu
i'm not sure if they're gonna come up in
one division but do you guys think
aim could somehow be behind this west
view
operation well why why couldn't it be
similar to
the sword logo that we're seeing why why
is this just not another identifier
another marker
on the game board of juan division from
whatever this entity is that's creating
this world
swords hexagons hedge clippers we don't
know they all mean something they all
they all mean something eric i'm like
many of your fans i've stayed up day and
night
deconstructing these theories the
numerology the symbols are everywhere
but i i think that it's probably what's
just right in front of us and that
that's the logo for a very famous evil
entity in the uh
in the marvel comic universe this is
probably its introduction into
a reintroduction into the cinematic
universe after
it was in obviously iron man 3 but it
will be thrust again into the forefront
i think with hydra
no longer really being a threat yeah i
totally agree i think that
you know at first i was like no they're
just referencing the hex magic
that wanda is known for because maybe
they're just trying to tie into it's no
longer just weird
you know weird uh powers it's actually
magic that she's going to be using but
then you know after a few
new rockstars videos i was like there's
actually one too many connections there
and so now i do now i'm kind of back on
the bandwagon okay this probably is aim
i mean it's just
too much so sorry tom i'm so sorry i
radicalized you
but it was just but you know i don't
think that you know i don't think that
they were responsible for all the
problems in the world the number six but
i do think
aim is part of the show and and i was so
one theory i was thinking about is
what if what if we've been thinking
about this the wrong way what if
aim is actually the one who approached
wanda and was like
hey um you know we we got a way that you
can be with vision again
you know and uh so they brought her into
the loop and maybe they've even hooked
her up to something
so that way she can uh she can tap into
this world and her power to be with
vision but then
you know it's now gone kind of haywire
and now it's it's kind of blown up worse
than we have and that's why swords come
in to try to solve and fix the situation
so maybe like the hell's fire club
trying to control the phoenix
maybe this is aim trying to control
uh wanda and and losing that control and
now it's and maybe then all the people
who live there
are actually aim agents instead of just
constructs and they're
that's what that's what kind of got me
thinking about like maybe there's
like they they want to wait and extract
what they need to because
maybe by wanda being hooked up to this
thing that's uh that they're able to
um utilize the power of an affinity zone
essentially yeah
and maybe that's their way of doing this
i don't know i i like your thinking tom
and i know a lot of our viewers are
going yes thank you so much finally
going into it i
flatly disagree um
[Laughter]
well here's my issue with it it's like
marvel has
pulled this card before i get why people
think this could be possible because
we heard hale hydro you know come back
in winter soldier
we uh kevin feiger in comic con 2019 was
like hey remember the ten rings
they may have just seemed like a one and
done thing but they're coming back
um with aim i totally think aim could
come back in the mcu
i just think you know one division has
only um
two thirds of its episodes left they've
already laid a lot of groundwork getting
us to know what sword could be are they
really going to spend a lot of time be
like well in addition to sword
there's this whole other organization
that came back from the early mcu
that you're also going to have to get to
know it just seems a little muddy it
seems like there's a lot like here's
everything you need to know about these
guys now
yeah yeah it would be like halfway
through uh lost they're like hey the
dharma initiative
there's also another organization called
the
um the karma collective and uh
you also they're also great behind it
right yeah culture so
i i don't know i i think aim could come
back in the mcu i hope it comes back in
the mcu especially if mode
shows up i'm just relieved i'm really
happy to see that uh
wanda is using aim to get back together
with vision as a boy
i used aim to get back together with my
ex-girlfriend
aol instant messenger send a quick
message
online will you go put an away message
up thinking of you put your anniversary
in your profile put a song lyric
put maybe change the font color to pink
to let her know you're thinking about
her good job
i see you wanda you're romantic now
what i'll say is i think the hexagons
are important but maybe not as important
as we've been making it out to be you
know
we keep saying oh it's six there's six
sides to a hexagon six points so it's
the sign of the devil 666 i'm
mephisto i think could show up i don't
know if the hexagons will be connected
to that
but i think right now it's an aesthetic
choice
every episode ends with like a hexagon
wipe or in the opening credits of the
brady bunch episode there was hexagons
there
i think what we might see is some kind
of like bird's eye view of the outside
of west view and maybe it's just laid
out on a hexagonal
like gray yeah and that's it like it's
there's not any deeper right i mean it
could be something so simple like maybe
she wakes up
and there's a light above her that's in
the shape of a hexagon i'm like that's
it yeah it could probably be something
so simple but it definitely i went from
it's nothing it's just a
slight reference to okay now it's
something i just don't know everything
you were radicalized by the internet
a prominent force on the internet
radicalized you i just am now picturing
mephisto like emerging and he's just
draped in hexagons like
he's just got like hexagon bangles he's
got a hexagon
he's just like he's just like pushing it
into the screen
things where you pull yourself through
hexagon rings as we
saw when you know uh because i first got
into like
nerdy uh recaps reading jeff jensen's uh
articles after lost you know on
entertainment weekly
yeah that guy is now a writer on
watchmen and stuff like that so i'm like
there's a future for me to make this
stuff too
um but like one thing i learned
from doing that and you know a show like
hbo's watchman is good for this too
there
is a difference between things that are
important and things that are
the answer um some things can be super
important and come back and tell us
certain things about
understanding the show but are not the
answer to or not the number 42
the answer to everything um and like
just by
uh looking at the hexagons it can give
us some kind of importance that will be
revealed at the end of the show
but isn't necessarily the answer and the
answer can still be mephisto
but it doesn't mean the hexagons are
connected to that
um it's just like kind of what tom was
saying it might have been like a
hexagonal light or she
is her mind uh her body is strapped into
something there's like a hexagonal halo
that's over her
uh or that like um the spell that she
used to
cast um try to bring vision back to life
it was kind of this eldritch magic
looking sparkle thing that was in the
shape of the hexagon and it was called
hex magic
and then that blew up and now that's
what west view is
fargo kind of does that that's going to
say what like what fargo the tv show
does there's a lot of things that are
important but ultimately don't answer
anything you know and
fargo is produced by noah holly who also
did legion which i think there are a ton
of parallels with legion in one division
in um eric you were saying watchmen like
the theme
of and the concept of an egg was like
really important in that show but it was
and it kind of was the answer at the end
but it wasn't like every single thing
has to do with an
egg but it was an important symbol with
the show so it could just be that if
like
hexagons symbolically could mean a lot
of things and also it could be just like
a light or whatever
a bangle a nice bengal um marina
you tapped into my future ted talk
theory in which everything is
eggs uh uh it sounds stupid but i
am gonna write a book one day that
explains how everything in art and media
uh everything in life if you understand
fundamentally what an egg is
uh that is everything and i look at it
as a future spoiler alert for eric's oh
god we're watching the origin
it's gonna work it was an egg the whole
time it was an
egg that'll be eric super villain origin
you guys need to watch this uh this
short story
that they've animated on youtube called
the egg and it's like the most beautiful
thing in the world and i love it and i
watch it once a month and it's perfect
i'll put it in the comments and you guys
might already know what i'm talking
about
anyway let us know in the comments below
what you think this uh
this six or this recurring six or
absence of the number six or the
hexagons is really all about i wanna
hear your craziest theory
uh because i do love talking about it um
but we have time oh wait no
whoa whoa okay so marina for saying that
everything's eggs and allowing me to
soapbox you get a golden sparkle box
does it come with you also get a golden
sparkle box
because even though i don't agree with
your aim theory i like that you have
thought about it more than i have
and tommy you get another blue one
okay i don't have a reason you just
kidding and you deserve it
it's so sad it's it's all fun and games
and we have a good time here
but growing up i didn't have much uh you
know
hot dogs and macaroni and cheese for
dinner four or five nights a week
uh dad wasn't around and uh gold sparkle
bucks were really all i had to look
forward to
you know i find myself as an adult now
with my son
disappointed in me as i was with my
father thinking that maybe
a golden sparkle box would have saved
today but uh
a blue one is fine and we'll regroup and
i
am just happy to get a chance to to talk
with my peers and i wish everyone the
best of luck
all right tommy i'm taking away one of
your blue sparkle bugs
the cold truth is that dessert in
tommy's house was a can of alfredo sauce
yeah it was that's why i can't get
enough of it
when i get married my wife and i are
gonna smear alfredo sauce in each
other's face with a spoon
all right we got time for one final
rogue
question uh everyone's gonna answer this
and the one i like the best will
get a sparkle buck of some kind uh our
question this week
in political news vermont senator
patrick leahy
new president pro tempore of the senate
and third in line
of succession the president wait a
minute it goes vice president speaker
the house president
that's right um so third or fourth yeah
um has cameos this guy is great uh
batman fans know this guy
he loves batman he is in all the batman
movies he's the one who says
uh we don't cower the thugs and the
joker's like you remind me of my father
that's patrick leahy uh he is also in
batman v superman he's
on the um the senate panel next to old
crooked
mouth what's her face holly hunter
i drank paige tate she's an adorable
crooked mouth i love holly hunters so
freaking oh my god um and uh he's the
one next to her he's another
senator anyway this guy loves batman and
he is president pro tempore
he will be presiding over the
impeachment proceedings because the
chief justice is like i ain't touching
that [ __ ]
um so i want to know from you guys what
is the most batmanny legislation
that patrick leahy could try to pass no
guns no killing
yeah there we go wear a mask not for
your own protection but for the people
you love
isn't that a lesson from batman have all
kids learn martial arts
so they could back you up if you need it
it's also just repealing all taxes on
rich people so that
if you are rich you can just become
batman like if you're
if you're rich you need to be able to
become a superhero so like no more taxes
well i'm gonna give the golden sparkle
book to
tommy bechtold on that one redemption
buddy
redemption you got it you gotta run home
tomorrow
a golden sparkle buck just for me wow
but i'm not the guy who ever wins
i'm always mr second place i'm always mr
runner up here
now i'm drunk with power well you didn't
win
tom michaelson tom michaelson is our
winner with his two
sparkle books congratulations tom
michelson yeah
thanks guys now tommy's devastated again
yeah i just love snatching things out of
the closet
dangle it and then knock it up well
that is it for this episode of rogue
theory i want to thank our guest tommy
bechtold marina mastros tom michelson
follow all of them on social media
support all of their wonderful things
they say and do
uh you can support our channel by
checking out one of our many great merch
options like this i am eric voss shirt
and our other one division inspired
designs an unusual couple
we're selling out of those quickly uh
check this out at newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to new york stores on youtube
and another reminder to download the
stereo app by going to stereo dot com
slash new rockstar so that you can
listen to our three
new weekly live shows it's not just our
shows on stereo you can join
conversations about a wide range of
conversation topics
comedy pop culture and sports download
the app for free on
apple and android and create an avatar
and profile be sure to download now so
you can submit questions to one of our
upcoming shows
see you next time boners
[Music]
you